hello and welcome to this video playing
yes Ches Ches Ches okay let's go one if
for for a change get some different
openings yeah Scandinavian not what I
know really that sometimes the issue if
you play I'm if you play you for only on
a very irregular basis you get some
sideline and you have really very little
idea what what what is what the theory
is I think this is something that is
known this looks looks familiar somehow
okay does that continue ships III I
think this should be for me know bishops
III whoa what are you going to do here
to e4 what's the deal I can also castle
long now
yeah that's Castle long
we should be 5 is also also possible him
[Music]
Jeff let's see 6 looks very normal I
still have a hard time to believe this
Queenie form but probably this is what
is going to do well the Queen hasn't any
doesn't have any other decent squares
and then I have to trade Queens I don't
really want to do that what about the
smooth 4g4 okay unfortunately I cannot
take on g7 because of Queen g5 but after
inserting this move I might be able to
do it
I have to briefly okay I am back after
having lost tons of time I had to take
the call though it was of course totally
unimportant that I still had to take it
yeah okay and then then you miss stuff
like that of course okay let's see how
bad it really is maybe it isn't all that
bad
we should be five is still quite
annoying Here I am attacking the bishop
and night yeah yeah I've got f4 I
believe f4 Queen shakes
he's got Queenie for at the end that's
the thing yeah okay I still have to do
it problem Quincy five I could close
them okay but I'm threatening t3 here so
he still cannot easily evacuate group
the eight or something don't see it I
mean I don't see it means I don't see
anything special going on hey I should
be clearly better with the bell but
black Kings stuck in the center but yeah
I've lost so much time it's going to be
difficult to finish this game
normally maybe a six
okay here I'm happy to have Luke he1
coming just centralize everything and
try to catch the black King time warning
we just Castle short check J I'm not so
happy with this but couldn't could not
invest more time there he will take this
I guess and I'm just a pawn up it's not
that bad
but it won't be easy to finish off
I can should be 60m this is was not so
great I think I came didn't see that h2
was hanging of course okay yeah it's
still raw even though he puts the points
on the wrong squares but you can still
not do much
9f5 there was age five unfortunately our
third after that I would have played on
I mean they cannot lose then yeah I just
get to go over if I've taken the pawn
but it's of course a draw
yeah that was a game that was killed by
the time loss in the opening basically
otherwise I think I would have won that
the the white position is just great iam
but just gifting like two minutes is a
bit much
yeah Bishop g7 wasn't probably all that
great I mean okay but okay this
resulting position is good yeah ever
want this and okay man this is this is
tough even if you have time check yeah
this yeah I mean once you see it it does
it looks very logical to this looks
fantastic and yeah for this is supposed
to rain threatening just to centralize I
guess it's difficult to suggest you move
for black yeah yeah this wasn't bad
either
yeah I saw that but I didn't see a
crooks III I didn't see interesting more
have it okay ff5 is not bad
a 94 spent tonight okay but I had to be
quick they're already 94 it's not
exactly difficult to see
[Music]
check and here you escaped into a worse
ending that that he held tonight a7 or
him yeah ah him I didn't see that I have
the the four cam ha
the Knight f5 of course is the betcha
move ya know Bishop d2 where was that
was a big one Oh threatening made on c1
and maybe I was too hectic there yeah I
always had this feeling like I have no
time and I have to play rushed and so on
maybe I mean I still have 50 seconds now
that was probably an issue him that I
felt a little bit too rushed and played
everything immediately and not trying to
kill this off yeah anyway a bit of a
mishap at beginning there thanks for
watching